next question is from Ken how do you
start conversations with strangers
there's no single answer to this it
really kind of depends on the context
and the social situation like here where
we have other offices and we have a
shared common area you're probably going
to start a conversation around things
happening in the building the horribly
oppressive construction the dead going
on around us or Oh what did you bring
for lunch today or did you see that a
Keurig has shown up in the kitchen
thanks to a viewer who sent this one or
whatever else if you're watching sports
at a sports bar I would guess that you
would maybe start a conversation around
what's going on in the game or something
like that if you are at a business
networking event it's probably gonna be
a question oh so who what do you do who
do you work for something like that
there's really I think sometimes the
problem with these questions is the idea
that there is one way to start a
conversation with strangers in every
circumstance especially with like pickup
lines for example yeah it has to be
situational I think you're so into
what's your favorite type of cereal and
debate over that no that would be a
weird opener that would be a weird
opener but maybe maybe in some way
endearing if it's done in a non-creepy
way threatening or threatening way on
airplanes I think the obvious one is are
you coming from home or going home or
something like that and then that leads
into whatever I never want to start with
a negative thing though it's always easy
to point out the crappy things that are
going around on around you first yeah
but like maybe like the construction
noise or if you're on a flight the ways
been delayed you're not gonna be
perceived as someone who's too
optimistic and upbeat if you start going
negative have a conversation with that's
true an easy one for me is anytime I see
someone wearing an Argentine soccer
jersey or if I just overhear Spanish
being spoken with an Argentinian accent
I'm right in there that's sort of
assuming you're not in Argentina if
you're in Argentina then it's kind of
like well yeah what do you buy a novel
it has to be a novel novel thing cars is
one where if you're somewhere and you
see an interesting car you can very
easily sort of approach someone and ask
about the car now why you would want to
I don't really know why you have to be
making conversation in parking lots it's
not something I feel well you're the car
person traveling if you hear Americans
when you're abroad that is often easy if
you're traveling it's
of easy also because if you talk to
locals they'll immediately realize
you're not from there and most people
are nice and kind of want to help you or
give you advice so I find that in
general when traveling it's very easy to
start conversations with strangers I
don't know I was in Madrid once and I
was walking by a KFC and I saw another
group of Americans also walking by the
same KFC and they were just beside
themselves wanting to take pictures of
the whole thing and I wanted nothing to
do with them those are the Americans you
don't want to have anything to do with
right the people that seek out Burger
King and KFC when traveling through
Europe no interest on my part in talking
to those people yeah I would definitely
pretend to be Canadian in that case or
just Argentinean I would I would just
stand about and I don't speak English I
only speak Spanish